The congressional committee
investigating the January 6th
insurrection is considering a
possible criminal referral for
Steve Bannon and former
President Donald Trump is
basically telling Republicans
not to vote in future
elections. For more on this,
it's time for a closer look.
I don't have to tell you the
last 19 months of pandemic life
have been a slog. You can just
tell by looking at the before
and after of this show. I mean
19 months ago, I was in a suit
and tie, laser focused on the
day's top stories. Now, I'm
here going on tangents, dressed
like an assistant manager at a
sprint store. Things have
changed. People used to come up
to me and say they love the
show. Now, they ask me, what's
Wally like in real life?
Who told you you could write
applaud for Wally on a card? I
didn't. I I didn't. This card
wrote itself. Oh boy.
Part of the slog, of course,
has come from the difficulty in
getting more people vaccinated
and overcoming right-wing
misinformation about vaccines.
There have been all sorts of
wild claims swirling on the
far-right fringes at one point,
Reuters was forced to publish
an article with this very real
headline, fact check, a vaccine
did not turn characters in the
movie I Am Legend into zombies.
That's not a fact check. That's
a plot check. That sounds like
someone at Reuters just wanted
to get paid to watch I Am
Legend. Are you telling me the
time my mom asked, who is the
guy in the movie with Jennifer
Lopez where she's the maid? I
can just yell, I don't know,
call Reuters. And the main
reason you know vaccines don't
turn people into zombies is
that there was even time to
fact check it. In zombie
movies, the newscaster always
anchors screaming before the
screen goes to static. And 28
days later, there wasn't a news
report where some dude said,
did a rage virus from a monkey
eradicate human life in less
than a month? We rate the
statement mostly true. They've
reached the studio. It is worth
remembering amid all this that
there is actually a very large
pro vaccine consensus in this
country. Last month, the poll
found that 79% of Americans are
vaccinated or planned to get
vaccinated and yesterday, the
White House released new data
showing that 77% of eligible
Americans have already received
at least one shot. Which is
great news. It means slowly but
surely we're overcoming the
small but vocal group of
right-wing conspiracy theories
spreading dangerous
misinformation like Donald
Trump's former national
security adviser, Mike Flynn
who claimed at one point that
they were putting the vaccine
in salad dressing. You know,
somebody sent me a thing this
morning where they're talking
about putting the vaccine into
salad dressing or salads. Have
you seen this? Yes. Have you
seen this? I mean, it's and I'm
and I'm thinking to myself,
this is the bizarre world,
right? This is definitely the
bizarre world. If you're
wondering which one General
Flynn was, he's the one wearing
the shirt that says General
Flynn.
We live in a country where the
former national security
adviser starts a sentence with.
Somebody send me a thing.
That's what your grandpa says
right before you have to change
all of his passwords for him.
Also, with regard to the salad
dressing, I think you're
misreading the label, the
valley is hidden, not the
vaccine.
Sal, Sal wrote that one.
Also, if a vaccine could be
effectively delivered via salad
dressing, don't you think
that's how we'd be doing it?
People are afraid of needles.
No one's afraid of dressing
except that radish in the don't
drown your food PSA. Anybody
here born between seventy-1 and
76? Alright, great. Seriously.
Could you imagine how much
higher our vaccination rates
would be if the choice was a
needle in the arm or a
tablespoon of ranch? If my
first shot was ranch, can my
second one be Russian dressing?
I'm asking 'cuz I just ate
corned beef. Also, why does
Flynn keep saying, have you
seen this? It's hard to take
these people seriously when
they start using the cadence
and catchphrase as stand-up
comedians. It's like Jay Leno
got super into queueing on.
Have you seen this? Have you
heard about this? A secret
group of the same worshipers is
controlling our government. I
feel like the floor is really
gonna fall out on a lot of
these impressions. Cuz when it
was just the crew, I'd say,
that sounded like Jay Leon,
right? They'd be like, right
away, Mr. Myers, you bet. It
was like he was in the room
with us, sir.
And then, of course, you've got
the right-wing megaphones of
Fox News and the Republican
Party amplifying vaccine
misinformation every day. For
example, we told you yesterday
about the baseless right-wing
claim that cancellations that
Southwest Airlines were caused
by protests against Joe Biden's
vaccine mandate. Even Trump
called into a right-wing radio
show and claimed that was what
was going on while also
gratuitously throwing in a
mention of his own gripes about
the election he lost. I think
it has a lot to do with a lot
of things. I think it has
something to do with the
election that we rigged. I
think I think these are big
fans of your favorite
president, Howie. I think that
this has something to do with
that. I think it has something
to do with the, I think it has
a lot to do with the mandates
where they're just not going in
and you know, they're gonna
destroy the economy with what's
happening right now cuz you
have, this is just the
beginning. Yeah, sure. Pilots
are so upset about the election
results, they staged a sick out
11 months later. Ladies and
gentlemen, this is your captain
speaking. It's a bony 78
degrees in Los Angeles.
Unfortunately, we won't be
going there because Democrats
stole the election We'll just
be circling here 20 miles west
of Newark until Joe Biden is
removed by the cyber ninjas. At
this point, Trump could see
anything and think it's about
his election loss. I was at
Kroger the other day and they
were out of avocados. They
said, they said the drivers of
the avocado delivery trucks
were walking out in protest
because the election was
rigged. Avocados, we love
avocados, don't we fool? It's
just like the classic song, you
say avocado, I say avocado. I
never had the first time I had
one. I was at a Trader Joe's
and I said to the manager, how
much? How much for one of your
precious green dinosaur eggs?
And she said to me, she said to
me, tears in her eyes. She
said, sir, that is a
single-seated tropical fruit.
These Southwest conspiracy
theories are such a shame too
because if you ask me, there's
really only one big takeaway
from the Southwest Debacle.
You're off the hook, Sprint.
Sprint.
Sal. Sal, just ADR, ADR in
spirit for sprint and then take
out. You're off the hook
spirit.
You're no longer the go-to joke
airlines over at Spirit
Headquarters. They're popping
champagne. Of course, they're
tiny air paint. It's gonna take
a second to get back on track,
of course. Of course, it's
spirit. We're gonna get you
back with this really, there's
a really good joke coming.
It's a I don't wanna put too
much on it but it's a sound
effect joke. And I'm telling
you right now, it's gonna save
what's happened to this closer.
Of course, it's spirit, there
are tiny airplane bottles of
champagne. So, when you pop
them, it sounds like this.
Oh, gotta start listening to
the sound effects before the
show. Either way, spirit is
psyched to be like if five guys
got caught. You're like a five
guys guts. Either way, spirit
is psyched to be like if five
guys got caught selling horse
burgers, everyone at Arby's
would be like, it's our time
now. Anyway, what was I saying?
The modern GOP is a male stream
of authoritarian impulses and
unhinged conspiracy theories.
Sure sounds like something I'd
say. For example, my pillow CEO
Mike Lindell was on Steve
Bannon's podcast earlier this
week and said he wants to get
as many as 25 states to
participate in his sham
election audits to prove that
Trump actually won. Getting all
these states on board, we've
got right now upwards of nine.
I wanna get at least 25 on
board and when I say before
Thanksgiving. We are bringing
the case to them before
Thanksgiving, everybody. Now,
whether they accept it or not,
it's up to the supreme court. I
really believe that it'll be,
it'll be nine zero that they
accept the case and then when
we bring it, all the evidence
we dump it there. Why do you
why do you think, hang on, hang
on, slow down. What is Mike
Lindell got? That's gonna
convince them just to even take
it up. Forget how they're gonna
rule. Just even take it up. The
evidence of an attack that who
have a foreign country on our
country, a cyber attack are the
biggest historical crime in
history. Everybody can see the
manifestation of that right
now. Dude, you have a
microphone. Why do you always
yell like you stopped your car
too far away from the
drive-thru speaker? And you
know what's bad when Steve
Bannon is telling you to slow
down with your conspiracy
theories? That's like DJ Khaled
telling you to cool it with the
air horn. Also, I love that
Bannon who definitely thinks of
himself as a brilliant
tactician and evil genius has
to team up with the pillow
dope. His podcast is gonna get
sued for copyright infringement
by the makers of Pinky and the
Brain. It's like Nick Fury had
to put together The Avengers
but the only heroes he could
find were visible man in the
human porch.
That one was mine. But I do
appreciate Lindell's confident
prediction that the Supreme
Court is gonna accept his case
9 to nothing. It makes it extra
fun to see him crash and burn.
It's like if Babe Ruth had
called a shot and then instead
of hitting a home run he struck
out, barfed on home plates,
slipped on the bar, farted, and
split his pants. Oh no, who are
we kidding? That definitely
happened a few times, right?
Also, why are you so intent on
getting it done by
Thanksgiving? You were saying
Trump was gonna be back in
office by August. Now,
Thanksgiving is your new
deadline. We're bringing the
case to them before
Thanksgiving so we can
reinstate Donald Trump in time
to eat some turkey. And watch
the Bears take on the Lions.
And while Bannon is busy
spitballing bad conspiracy
theories with the pillow
dingus. He's also obstructing
the congressional investigation
of the January 6th insurrection
by defying a subpoena from the
committee and now, the
committee is moving to pursue
possible criminal charges to
hold him accountable. Breaking
news in the investigation into
the January 6th capital attack.
The House Select Committee just
announced that they will move
to hold former Trump adviser
Steve Bannon in criminal
contempt for refusing to comply
with his subpoena. We have
engaged with a wide variety of
law enforcement offices
including the US Marshals in
order to issue the subpoenas
and we will use everything as
you said with all due respect.
We will use all of the agencies
and all of the tools at our
disposal to issue the subpoenas
and then enforce them. If
witnesses do not show up, we
will hold them in criminal
contempt. We will vote them in
contempt in the house and we
refer them for prosecution. So,
they might arrest Steve Bannon
Again? Bannon already looks
like he got pulled out of bed
in the middle of the night by
US Marshals. I feel like if
they kicked in his door, they'd
take one look at him and say,
oh, is someone here already?
Bannon already got arrested
once and pardoned by Trump
although from looking at him,
you'd think he'd escape
Shawshank style. If the feds
are looking for Bannon, I can
tell you where to find him. He
looks like the dude illegally
selling pet iguanas on the
boardwalk at Venice Beach. Oh,
this one's named Ricky. He
could sniff your salad dressing
to see if there's vaccine
hidden inside. Bannon is to
find the January 6th
investigation but his former
employer Trump still wants an
investigation into the 2020
election to somehow prove his
repeatedly disproven conspiracy
theories about the election and
now, he's basically telling
Republican voters, don't go to
the polls unless GOP
politicians get on board with
his lies. Former President
Donald Trump is sending a clear
message to Republicans, don't
vote. In a statement yesterday,
the former president urged his
supporters to focus on the last
election instead. Writing this,
If we don't solve the
presidential election fraud of
2020, which we have thoroughly
and conclusively documented,
Republicans will not be voting
in 22 or 24. It is the single
most important thing for
Republicans to do. I do like
that Trump is constantly making
life difficult for Republicans.
You just wanna use them to win
power. Sorry, you guys bought a
ticket on this train wreck and
now you can't get off. It's
kinda like when your spouse
makes you go horseback riding
and you say sure thinking it'll
take 20 minutes and not
realizing it's a three-hour
trail with no lunch breaks and
the horse hates you and stops
every 15 minutes to take a
dump. This is the GOP, a party
obsessed with unhinged
conspiracy theories. For
example, earlier this week,
South Carolina Senator Lindsey
Graham made this totally
incomprehensible claim about
migrants crossing the southern
border. We had 40, 000
Brazilians come to the Yuma
sector alone headed for
Connecticut wearing designer
clothes and Gucci bags. This is
not economic migration anymore.
People see an open America.
They've taken advantage of us.
I'm asking this in all
sincerity. What are you talking
about? Brazilians headed to
Connecticut with designer
clothes and Gucci bags. Are you
confusing the southern border
with an episode of The Real
Housewives? That? That sounded
like a random string of
nonsense words. You sound like
Siri after someone dropped
their iPhone in the toilet.
Siri, what are the lyrics to We
Didn't Start the Fire by Billy
Joel? Designer clothes without
the tags Brazilians wearing
Gucci bags. Thank you. Did you
know if you saw the dangers of
Trump and the whirlwind of lies
and conspiracy theories around
him and tried to use him to
ride back into power but now,
they're facing the consequences
of that decision. Trump's
accolade are facing possible
criminal charges for defying
subpoenas and Trump is still
spreading. That seemed early.
Was that a little? Maybe a
little early?
I mean, we still did sound
effects without an audience.
I don't know. I don't think, I
don't think people at home will
notice. Next, next, he's gonna
claim they're hiding votes in
salad dressing. This has been a
closer look.
God's Love We Deliver cooks and
brings over 2 million meals a
year to men, women, and
children living with HIV, AIDS,
cancer, and other serious
illnesses and they need your
help. Now more than ever, if
you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button,
stay safe, get vaccinated. We
love you.